a third day of Russian attacks against
Ukraine has led to further destruction
of Civilian targets a strike on a
crowded Market has left at least seven
people dead and eight more injured in
the town of of divka that's in Ukraine's
Eastern Donuts region and that's
according to the Region's Governor Pavlo
Kirilenko who said there was no military
Logic for such an attack
meanwhile Ukraine's allies are pledging
to help Keith for as long as it takes
following extensive missile and drone
strikes by Russia on multiple Ukrainian
cities the bombardment has targeted
civilians and energy infrastructure
leaders of the G7 group of Nations have
condemned the latest attacks as
indiscriminate and are vowing to hold
Russian President Vladimir Putin to
account
this scene is a reminder war is still at
their doorstep people in Kiev taking
shelter in a subway station
they were worn by Air Raid Sirens which
have repeatedly sounded since the
Russian barrage began on Monday
terrorism
if there's no infrastructure nearby
two walls in a basement will not save
you
recently is
ukrainians have been working quickly to
repair the damage the Russians targeted
power stations but also playgrounds
this can't be compared with anything
it's desperation with no end
they continue to attack us
they keep scaring us but we will resist
I'm going to work now of course we hide
and look for a safe space to shelter
we're scared for our lives
the southern city of zaparisia also
faced a new round of Russian missile
attacks a worker at this garage was
killed and the building destroyed
it's hard to express with words you're
mourning one of our co-workers and our
company is gone
50 people are now without a job and
another company nearby has been
destroyed too much
President Vladimir zielinski asked a
snap meaning of G7 leaders for more air
defense capabilities and to put even
more pressure on Russia
for this new wave of Terror there must
be a new wave of accountability for
Russia new sanctions new forms of
political pressure and new forms of
support for Ukraine
Russia says it does not Target civilians
but the broken windows and destroyed
homes are proof of the devastation
Ukrainian people are enduring
and for more on the current state of
Ukraine's infrastructure I'm joined Now
by Alexander commission he's the CEO of
the Ukrainian Railway Service uh thank
you for making a time for us this must
be very busy days for you Russia has
stepped up its attacks on civilian
infrastructure in the last few days
how's the rail network holding up
hi I'm thanks for inviton we keep
running no matter how heavily they show
us we find a way how we can repair and
get back to operations when we shall
power stations we release diesel Locus
when the Shell stations will get Windows
back and keep running and actually
indeed there is no military
infrastructure around us but they keep
shelling us and try to damage the
infrastructure now the a lot of Russian
strikes against Ukraine's energy
infrastructure you you mentioned that
you
um fight against that with using a
diesel locomotives how dependent is your
network on the electricity grid
well we had the largest consumer of
energy in the country and more than half
of our tracks are electrified so we'll
run electric logos and electric clockers
it's much more uh environmental friendly
and much more efficient than visual
logos but once they shell their power
stations why the show Once they show the
energy infrastructure we have to get
back to these Locus for some time until
the moment energy infrastructure is
repaired so we are ready to run our
service no matter what happens around
but that step back in terms of
environment and in terms of efficiency
so we're getting back to Electric logos
as soon as it's possible now at the
start of the conflict when Russia first
invaded your rail network played a key
role in helping evacuate civilians from
war-torn regions uh what we say is the
main focus of the rail network at this
stage in the war
once there was need to overquit people
we are ready to help we are ready to do
our job so once we see a weave of new
people willing to overquit temporarily
we are ready to support them with
nutrients and let them leave the cities
for some time that's our role in terms
of civilian evacuation and we are doing
pretty much for export of cargo that's
the key for the economy now and we are
trying to expand the capacity for cargo
experts because this again that's the
blood of our economy
but it is also your country's largest
employer with more than 230 000 staff
you've been praised for the Network's
ability to continue to operate during
wartime but the strain on your Workforce
must be immense how do your people cope
well from day one we are doing our job
and there is no way for us to step down
Alexander commission head of the
Ukrainian Railway service thank you very
much
thank you
NATO defense ministers are meeting in
Brussels today to discuss bolstering
Ukraine's air defense systems NATO Chief
Jens stoltenberg said the meeting comes
at a pivotal moment I think that
Ukraine's air defense is a top priority
the meeting at NATO headquarters is the
first since Russia illegally annexed
several Ukrainian territories and other
Sidelines 50 countries are meeting as
part of the Ukraine defense contact
group that's a separate group set up by
the United States to coordinate military
aid for Kiev the U.S Secretary of
Defense spoke of challenging months
ahead
Russia's latest barrage against Ukraine
cities has again killed and wounded
innocent civilians and put targets with
no military purpose in the crosshairs
we will continue to boost Ukraine's
defensive capabilities
for today's urgent needs and for the
Long Haul
now joining us from NATO headquarters in
Brussels is our correspondent Terry
Schultz Terry the U.S and NATO continued
to urge allies and the other countries
in the contact group to give more
weapons to Ukraine how are governments
likely to respond in this meeting today
that's right this is the eighth time the
Ukraine defense contact group has met
and behind closed doors the countries
are willing to discuss exactly what they
have to give Ukraine at this point we
saw some comments as ministers entered
the room for example Germany reminding
that it is just delivering this Iris T
air defense system to Ukraine and that
others would be on the way the Canadians
announced 50 million dollars more in
both equipment and things like winter
clothing and this is something that uh
that is going to be increasingly
necessary as this war heads into the
winter season which we we know is is
very bitter in Ukraine there are also
other contributions of of more tanks
more more land defense systems you know
Ukraine is calling for air defense but
you can't uh you can't give up the the
fight on the ground as well in which
Ukraine has had remarkable success so
while we do hear that they are going to
be focusing on how to bolster air
defenses
um they're really trying to close any
Gap in Ukraine's defenses here at this
meeting today
so how United are NATO allies in their
pledge for support of Ukraine
they're more united than ever and and
you know I'm not just saying that uh
these new attacks on Ukrainian cities
across the country has certainly
galvanized NATO to to basically heed
Ukraine's long-standing calls that it
needs more air defense that despite this
progress on the ground civilians can be
severely harmed by Russia's air assaults
and there's nothing tanks can do to stop
that so that's something that certainly
is in front Focus here at this meeting
today as we just saw these these deadly
attacks and we did see that that Germany
of course is giving this Iris T system
that it had planned for itself so this
is a change that we're seeing in allies
countries that once said you know we've
got nothing in our arsenals to give
anymore are starting to divert shipments
they meant for themselves for their own
National arsenals directly to Ukraine
uh now you've
stolten back and a number of other
people have mentioned that bolt string
air defense is currently the main issue
there the main focus for NATO analysis
support uh Ukraine but uh how else is
NATO uh or indeed the members of the
contact group uh supporting uh Ukraine
well one of the things that countries
are having to look at now as they give
weapons off their shelves and their new
deliveries to Ukraine is how they're
going to replenish their own stocks
because of course that's NATO's job to
defend uh to defend allies against a
potential attack so they can't really
empty their own stockpiles to support
Ukraine so one of the things that will
be really important here at the NATO
meeting when it's just the 30 allies
around the table plus Finland and Sweden
is how they're going to speed up
manufacturing processes how they're
going to redirect their budgets to to
buy more weapons that they already had
because now they're giving them to
Ukraine this is something that's long
plagued NATO allies they they have long
been called upon to make joint purchases
to speed up ammunition production that's
something that is really again going to
be important now that that their shelves
are emptying uh and sent to Kiev
DW's Terry Schultz there from the NATO
defense ministers meeting in Brussels
thank you very much Terry
Russia's Federal Security Service FSB
says it has detained eight suspects it
claims are connected to last week's
explosion that damaged the bridge
connecting Russia and Crimea the FSB
said the suspects include five Russians
and three Ukrainian and Armenian
citizens they are being held for what
Russia is calling a terrorist attack
allegedly organized by Ukraine's Secret
Service Ukraine has not claimed claimed
responsibility for the blast and has
called moscow's investigation nonsense
joining us now from Riga sdw's Kilian a
buyer I should add that Deutsche Villas
reporting from Russia has been
restricted since the Russian government
shutdown our Moscow Bureau earlier this
year Kilian uh tell us more about these
arrests
well the FSB has come down come out with
a very detailed plan of how allegedly
this bomb traveled from Odessa through
Bulgaria to Georgia Armenia and back
into Russia then or into Russia then
back through Georgia
um they have also said that they have
arrested two other Ukrainian Nationals
who were allegedly planning Terror
attacks they came through Estonia one of
them was carrying anti-aircraft weapons
they said and one of them an anti-tank
weapon
um this seems to be this information
these reports seem to to help underline
The Narrative that the Kremlin is
pushing and the program media is pushing
the claims that Ukraine is a terrorist
state
now Killian remind us of why that
damaged bridge to Crimea is such an
important symbol for Russia and indeed
for Vladimir Putin himself
well Vladimir Putin profited from a
surge of popularity after Russia under
his command illegally annexed Crimea
this Crimean Bridge which was built
under Putin's directive was his pet
project he opened it driving an orange
truck across this bridge and it was a
symbolism really of Russia's return to
power the restoring of the Empire one
could say now that this bridge has been
attacked by ukrainians it comes as a
heavy blow to the Kremlin especially in
recent light of other military defeats
on the battlefield
CW's Kilian Bayer in Riga there for us
thank you Killian